You are listening to radio lab radio from
W N y. S. T. E.
Hey, I'm Jad Abumrad. I'm Robert
Krulwich. This is radio lab. So Robert,
one of my favorite sounds of all time
is the sound of hearing people think,
you know, have a hearing,
a mind kind of formulate a thought
that wasn't there until it clicks in.
Yeah. That's just an
MP, a beautiful sound,
especially when the mind that you're
listening to is a person who has shaped
you, has shaped the show. Sure. So, uh,
today a little bit of a departure, um,
a couple of months ago I got connected
to a guy named bill Hayes as a mutual
friend, sort of put us in touch.
He wrote a really good book
actually about anatomy. Really good.
I gave it to my son. Really? Yeah.
He is a writer and a photographer
and I was the partner of
the late Oliver Sacks.
And together we made tapes or recordings
of conversations in the last year
of his life. Now, all of our Sachs, one
of the great, great writers of science,
masterful, masterful writer, you know,
we here at radio lab have grown
up with him and his style of,
of combining sort of clinical scientific
observation with deep humanity and
poetry. I feel like we're always trying
to walk in his footsteps in some way.
Can we do what we do? And certainly we
know we've had him on the show many,
many, many times. So his voice
will be familiar to a lot of you.
But what you hear on these tapes is
an altogether different portrait.
And why, why did you
start these recordings?
Well,
Oliver got his diagnosis of a
terminal cancer in mid January,
he had had cancer about nine years
earlier, dealt with it, but it was back.
It's spreading through his body.
The prognosis was six to 18
months and it was shattering
shortly after bill says they were
sitting at the kitchen table talking like
I, uh, I, I knew that he had things
on his mind that he wanted to write.
And I said, well, what do you,
what do you thinking about writing?
This was about four days after he got
his diagnosis and he paused and then he
looked at me and he said, uh,
something like a month ago I
felt that I was in good health,
even robust health at 81.
I still swim a mile a day,
but my luck has run out. And
uh, I said stop right there.
And I grabbed a pad and a
pen and I said, start over.
And I began writing as fast as I could
as he dictated virtually the entire
essay. Wow. Just sort of spilled
out like that. Yup. And uh,
so we had the idea of getting
a little audio recorder,
a digital recorder so that it
could be on hand at any time,
whether to record what he wanted to
write or reminisce or to collect stories
after his, I put the
recorder in a drawer and um,
didn't pull it out again until over
a year and a half after his death.
I didn't even listen to it, any
of it to write my own memoir.
I had been kind of very nervous about
listening to them cause I thought it'd be
very sad and just so that it would
just make me depressed and sad.
But I took it,
I took the recorder out of the drawer
where it had sat for 18 months and I
pushed play.
And of course it didn't work because
the batteries were dead because I had to
scramble to find batteries. And
when I did and then pushed play.
Okay.
This is a recorded
conversation between o w s and
Billy Hayes. Um, on February six,
the hairs on my arms went up.
It was as if he was alive. This was
the first recording you made with them?
It was a during dinner.
We're eating at the time and he
began telling me about his dream,
um, dreams.
I ain't been having a look of
strangely Arthur titled Reading
[inaudible] I have to make,
yeah, getting lost. Um,
and getting found full of supplies.
There's the maybe go through a door,
which I think will be a door
to another one, but there's a,
don't want to have a
mountain landscape. Um, um,
sometimes frightening with
Enes or, or habitat edge long,
very narrow ledgers,
but then finally come into
some gracious heavenly
mounting meadow and then waking dreams
about doing this and approaching him.
And um, it's a journey
from where to where,
this was February 6th,
2015 so about three weeks after Oliver
got his diagnosis of a terminal cancer
and his immediate impulse was to write
and yet
[inaudible] finance has
been forced into my mind
framing the evidence past two weeks,
Oliver was quite deaf,
even louder than he realized he
would whisper words to himself
as he wrote them down on the pad
and he wrote with a fountain pen.
Okay.
For Oliver, writing was a form of
thinking and the primary activity.
Yeah. For a human being,
I know my normal health
stay to health and energy at least such
health and energy as a fits as a fit and
active 81 year old ruled to enjoy in this
despite having,
I know the previous month and liver
full melanoma test to see this
thing is all out. This is from there out.
What I'm going to do is just leave that
all there so you can look at it again.
You asked her, no, no, nothing was
with a strong intent. I'm a creature.
Multiple drafts as you know,
specific symptoms,
feeling meaning
screws with the
screws with them and which may be hungry.
Severe tolerably, serious,
severe susa creations.
Fictions patients, patients.
We're known for death. We known for death
magnifying glass. Yeah. I haven't had,
Oliver was the kind of guy who would
take dictionaries to bed to read with a
magnifying glass. Can you bring my chain
mistakes? Real look up a word for me. I
need a magnifying glass
and I have one here.
I also feel the missing
magnifying glass. There it is.
Can you see if there's a
word visit piece of all VSI
yes,
there is change to a better
frame of mind to be wise.
To be wise. Um, can you pull
out the big Dick screened CFU.
Com find any. So impulse in particular.
I want to know whether
overturned to health. Okay.
Here's a man with a huge
vocabulary and love of writing,
but still every day you'd be struck
by a word that he wanted to look up.
Well,
it immediately says repentance for
misconduct or to do say repentance for
misconduct, recognition of errors,
committed return to a
better mind or opinion.
What's the origin of the word?
To recover one senses
come to oneself again.
Hope to learn some skills. I think
Russell credit the word I want.
Can I take
[inaudible]? Mistasis is coming back.
It's coming back.
[inaudible] trans through crest.
Christine say thank you very much.
Ranted for contingently.
You can expect it had happened for health.
Who [inaudible] through some harm
please.
Okay.
[inaudible] [inaudible] yes.
A general feeling of disorder. It is,
especially when things are going wrong
internally when homeostasis is not being
maintained.
When the autonomic balance starts
listing heavily to one side or the other,
that is core consciousness. The feeling
of how one is takes on an intrusive,
unpleasant quality, and now
one will say, I feel ill.
Something is amiss at such times one.
Indeed everything comes and goes and
if one could take a scan or inner
photograph of the body at such times,
one would see vascular beds
opening and closing Paris dialysis.
Accelerating or stopping is the rest
squirming or tightening in spasms,
secretion. Suddenly increasing
or decreasing is if the
nervous system itself,
we're in a state of
indecision instability,
fluctuation and oscillation are of
the essence in the unsettled state.
This feeling of disorder, we lose
the normal feeling of the procedure.
They're relatively benign,
would lead to the death of a
huge mass of melanoma cells.
These in dying would give off a variety
of unpleasant and pain producing
substances. Soon after
waking from the embolization,
I was to be a sale by feelings
of excruciating tiredness
and proxy Isms of sleep
so abrupt they could pull axe me in
the middle of a sentence or a mouthful.
[inaudible]
delirium would seize me within seconds.
Even in the middle of handwriting,
I felt extremely weak and inert.
On Day 10 I turned a corner.
I felt awful as usual in the morning,
but a different person in the afternoon.
This was delightful and wholly unexpected.
I suddenly found myself full of physical
and creative energy and euphoria,
almost akin to Hypomania. Exuberant
thoughts rushed through my mind.
How much of this was a reestablishment
of balance in the body?
How much an autonomic rebound after
a profound autonomic depression,
how much other physiological factors
and how much the sheer joy of writing,
I do not know,
but my transformed state and feeling
where I suspect very close to it.
Nietzsche experienced after a period of
illness and expressed so lyrically in
the gay science
[inaudible]
gratitude pours forth continually as
if the unexpected had just happened.
The gratitude of a convalescent
for convalescence was unexpected.
The rejoicing of strength
that is returning of a
reawakened faith in a tomorrow
and the day after tomorrow of a sudden
sense and anticipation of a future of
impending adventures of
seas that are open again,
where's the ways the microphone
on this bloody thing? Well, okay,
you all recording this right?
The, the time is nine 20. Um,
in New York it would be
five hours difference with
Greenwich Mean Time and it is
Monday the ninth.
And that's the say the 20th
day after my embolization.
And just 48 hours till the next one.
End of recording pause.
On March 11th, Oliver had the
second embolization surgery,
which would cut off blood supply
to the tumors growing in his liver.
With the idea of that it would
give Oliver more time, more energy.
We'd been together six years.
I knew him well and yet, uh,
I'd never seen him
with such focus.
[inaudible] all right.
All right. Question.
Just constantly writing. Yeah. I
don't know what to call this piece.
They can title it [inaudible] half
on your own. Did glorious forest.
Well, I like the future. I still never
know. Sorry. I oh, that's excellent.
Yeah, that's it. Um, and
I think I need to put in,
otherwise I'm does to indicate why
they should have and I say to Billy,
who is a good deal younger,
who's younger than who is a
good deal younger than I am.
Originally I put who was
two thirds my age, um,
how I have to be precise. I like that.
Okay. It's really precise. Okay. Chris.
Exactly. Two thirds my age. Okay,
so that's that piece
for the New York Earth.
Yes. Okay. Have some insurer
and I'll hear students. Okay,
sure.
I like the idea of saying [inaudible]
is exactly two thirds of my age.
It's not, it's not a fraction that
you expect to see three quarters. Yes,
yes, but not two thirds.
I like the idea of putting a
tiny arithmetical conundrum.
Ninth Avenue, Reverie
published March 20th, 2015
[inaudible]
driving down ninth avenue,
choking on diesel fumes from a truck just
ahead of us. I say to my friend Billy,
he's exactly two thirds my age.
I wonder whether you will see the
end of internal combustion engines,
the end of oil, a cleaner world.
The thought zooms me away from
ninth avenue to a forest world
in particular to the one
described in that glorious forest.
So Ghillean Prance his book about his
39 visits to the Amazon in the past 50
years. He sees what we are doing
to the Amazon and its many peoples.
He speaks for conservation, sanity
reason before we destroy it all.
[inaudible]
I went to that glorious forest in 1996,
11 days of botany study and hiking,
seeing hundreds of different
species of trees in a single acre.
I'd planned before I became ill to go
to Madagascar to see its forests and its
unique font and other wildlife,
especially the lemurs.
I love Lemurs. One has to see them,
study them to grasp the
origin of our primate nature.
But most of the forests on Madagascar
have already been obliterated and not a
naturally lemurs are dying.
Honking horns bring me
back to ninth avenue.
I seem to have spent hours lost in
reverie thinking about the Amazonian and
Madagascan forests, lemurs the time
machine. But we have scarcely moved,
are still behind the stinking lung
destroying truck. Not In my life.
Billy answers.
Um, I, yes, I'm a,
yeah, I, I'd been reading a
lot of it allowed to Billy. Um,
this is according where Oliver is talking
on the phone to Lawrence Weschler aren
Weschler but anyhow, he,
um, I was due to have a, um,
a cat scan follow up on Thursday.
I was terrified to this. In fact,
what it did show was that 80% of
the metastasis in the liver, um,
had been destroyed by the
embolization. With luck.
I should have two or three
good months after this.
Um,
well I just hope that I come see friends
and white and maybe travel a little at
yeah. And I think next
month if I'm up to it,
I'm gonna go to London to say
hello and possibly farewell to um,
friends and family and um,
I can't think ahead beyond that.
Six, seven is still one short.
I don't want to assume, um,
semantics,
semantics
and then
treatments
inseparability into its
relation. Who I want to hear.
I want to hear over the years I filled
upwards of a thousand notebooks that
contents of a various,
but three of them have had a special
function to record abnormalities of
perception during times of sensory
impairments or deprivation.
The column notebook is a very
modest affair. It is quite small.
It slips easily into a pocket crucial
because I need to have it with me at all
times increasing deafness.
I'm more prone to miss
hearing what people say,
but miss hearings deceive on
entirely. You accept what you hear.
You accept what you see.
Every miss hearing is a novel surprise
and concoction and never gets used to
them.
The hundredth is as fresh as absurd and
as thought provoking as the first Ms.
Herring became miss hearing.
Take the car for a spin became
take the car for a swim.
I've noted that your hummus can
[inaudible] on carbs. Taylor
poems, sick time published.
It was heard as a big time cuttlefish.
Did you say a poetry bag and you said no.
I said a cool, sweet.
I love the idea of a poetry that yes,
I'm inclined almost to put them all in.
I think they should all be. We'll meet.
We'll make the point that
sound Trump central thing,
one surroundings, one's
wishes and expectations.
Conscious and unconscious can certainly
be coded terminance and mishearing,
but the real Mr flies at lower levels
in those parts of the brain involved in
phonological analysis and decoding,
doing what they can with distorted
or deficient signals from our ears.
These parts of the brain managed
to construct real words or phrases,
even if they are absurd.
And yet there's often a sort of style
or wit a dash and these instantaneous
inventions,
they reflect to some extent one's own
interests and experiences and I rather
enjoy them only in the
realm of mishearing.
At least my miss hearings can a
biography of cancer become a biography of
Kantor. One of my favorite mathematicians,
Taro cards can turn into Taro pods,
a grocery bag into a poetry bag,
all or numbness into oral numbness.
And a mere mention of Christmas Eve,
a command to kiss my feet.
Oops. No wonder I criminal rights anymore.
I must get more cartridges have
grown through this too quickly.
I want to reassure you all of these
thoughts are already in the drought.
[inaudible] okay,
so I think it's time to let
your weary mind rest. Yes.
Okay. You see each other
in the morning? Okay.
[inaudible] kiss. We were never
had a dry mouth. I didn't have him.
Do you want some more water? Yes, I
bet. To raise my head in the fall.
Hello. This is David from Berlin.
Radiolab is supported in part by
the Alfred p Sloan Foundation,
enhancing public understanding of science
and technology in the modern world.
More information
aboutSloan@wwwdotsloan.org
hey, this is jad. Radiolab is supported
by rocket mortgage by quicken loans.
Chances are you're confident when
it comes to your work, your hobbies,
and your life.
Rocket mortgage gives you that same level
of confidence when it comes to buying
a home or refinancing your existing
home loan. Rocket mortgage is simple,
allowing you to fully understand all
the details and be confident that you're
getting the right mortgage
for you. To get started,
go to rocket mortgage.com/radiolab
equal housing lender licensed in all 50
states and m l s consumer
access.org number 30 30
this is Michael Barrels
from Portland, Oregon.
Radiolab is supported
by dash digital cash,
a revolutionary form of money that allows
anyone to make instant secure payments
anywhere in the world,
whether you're doing business overseas
or sending money home to friends and
family dash transactions costs
pennies and arrive instantly.
Dash is digital cash for information,
visit [inaudible] dot org slash Radiolab
I'm former US attorney Preet Bharara
and my new podcast is called, stay tuned.
If you look at areas
where he is unconstrained,
his behavior is pretty consistently
awful. It's about the human side of power.
Those who do not study history
are doomed to repeat it.
And those who study policing, no, we don't
study history and it's about justice,
fairness and democracy.
I have never had anyone who
committed the crime of murder.
Go back to prison ever again.
Presented by w NYC Studios,
cafe and Pineapple Street media.
Stay tuned is available
wherever you listen to podcasts.
[inaudible]
would you like to pull out some
wine for your elderly Laffer? Sure.
You want some of this?
You look very happy.
Which one of these jackets appeals to
you? Um, if you're going to pick one,
let's go to the start. Of course. I
have to take my own unfortunate shape.
No, no, no. I know. I want you to
respond to them. Which one is, oh,
I see you like this,
I think is fond of this sort of
routine jackets for this pockets.
Flaps functional though. It is.
I don't know where I got picture. Sorry.
It's so hot. Hot, hot. Do
you know that word sexy?
Yes. Right. You're very handsome.
You haven't had anything to, you
should have something to read.
I might go out
sort of enjoy that on Sunday night.
[inaudible] get a little stoned
and I go out into the neighborhood.
Do you mind?
I don't know the time.
Good from [inaudible]
environment or girl rejoice.
Um,
I wasn't counting how many
to do rubric counts there.
Oliver had enjoyed a couple of really
good months of feeling well and fit and
uh, getting lots of writing done. You
had completed not only a general
feeling of disorder, the short piece,
ms hearings, his autobiography
on the move was published.
He worked on a piece on the evolution of
the eye and he'd completed a major case
history on the performer, Spalding gray.
We'd made this wonderful trip to London
for 10 days after we returned from the
trip.
He knew that he would have to get another
cat scan to see how things were going.
And I, I would say that we kind of
had a feeling, an optimistic feeling.
He seemed to be doing well. So he
went into that hoping for the best,
but it was exactly the opposite.
The cancer had spread beyond
the liver to other organs. Um,
that it, uh, was looking very bad indeed.
Oliver more than anyone I think
knew that time was running out.
[inaudible] um, um,
I wonder if I could ask you to look
up something on the little box. Sure.
Uh, the 10 come on was, yeah,
in particular the warm about,
um, PV is definitely
heavily, I know, sure.
What did I say exact exact wording is
remember the sabbath day to
keep it holy. That's fine.
To be is right down that town.
Exactly what I want
to take the time to finish
this show up us,
he was having a lot of discomfort and
had to have a catheter implanted in his
abdomen to drain off fluid that
was accumulating from the tumors,
which was around August 4th or fifth.
It was really the only solution and, uh,
it was quite uncomfortable and
it had to be drained daily.
Um, and it also unfortunately
ended his swimming.
He was a great swimmer and he loved
to swim, but he didn't complain.
Swimming had come to an end,
so he put his head down basically
and began working on this essay.
Sabbath
screws. You're going big to take time
for you.
[inaudible] [inaudible]
you're doing showing my kids.
What'd you do? She, Tom was doing,
I knew it. I just wanted to talk.
Good morning. Good morning.
I miss the dramatic reading.
Just started a little
while ago. How are you?
Is Longtime assistant editor
Kate, what are you writing about?
[inaudible] Yup.
And spiritually. Personally.
[inaudible] okay. [inaudible]
why don't you come to share? I
drove from how to you're doing room.
I liked standing was better. Okay, fine.
Stamp Man. That shit loom over here.
Okay. My mother has 17 drugs. Is this,
how's an orthodox figuring out old
photographs of that father? Show him.
Wear a Yamaka and I was
told that he woke up.
You fixed her last year in February.
So funny. I love that. My Shaw,
the two K for the Orthodox
back, clairvoyant,
but they were very conscious
of the six. Come on.
Remember the facade of the
t t probate. I'm sure those,
as we call this proud bitch, fuck wait,
is entirely different from the rest
of the week. When shoppers came in,
my mother would light capitals. How
could lift favors from that happens?
Have you ever been afraid
like gradually became more
distant pull in different,
just different to Jewish
life. That's to their guard.
Let's talk about this to
the Croc in particular.
There was no particular
[inaudible] shop until I was 18
which was the French Chava
[inaudible] compelled me to four years.
I haven't dominated shirt. I said,
it's just a feeling. I don't tell him
[inaudible] [inaudible] he did tell her
the dex water. She came down with
the look of horror on her face.
I'm shrieked. You're in a folder nation.
I was sure this would be both the
backs of a sniff eventually. Then
under cordiality love was
refills. What's her fruitful,
hateful words? Her crows,
Reiki hated Judaism.
Fully relational in that capacity
for any humor, bigger
tree groups, brutal to
determine. Part two, a self pay to
so secure seven plus it over six or
so. Alright, filtered Vishal, clear four.
This is your partner with
adults. Athlete is bright enough.
[inaudible] your mom does would still
echoes with primer and Billy too was
warmly received and the stroke at
the terror bigotry of 60 [inaudible].
This was very funny too.
Afraid, afraid, eager and she was fed.
Her piece of the song stopped for a long
time. Upside tide. Your
[inaudible] process consists
of this bizarre and of course
that's how you get able to trust hard
to probably life can be conformed,
trained, exploration of bisects round.
I was fine until the
closeups facing the world.
Goofy fee. [inaudible]
locked up and sorry,
I know. Week short of dress. All right,
what's for Brussels? Melted
away probably carrots
and my force increase degree,
not of the supernatural.
This has been for base trips
today. Partial divorces,
great fight and different
food works for our life.
Achieving a sense of peace.
We do work so I framed my fault.
What's happened in your
day of rest? Several food
capsules separate from three when
one could feel work to start.
I'm on the baby food crops. It's waste.
On August 14th, Sabbath was
published in the New York Times.
That same day he began to dictate the
table of for the river of consciousness,
the collection of essays which he
knew would be published posthumously.
It was getting his house in order.
Um,
I don't know that I'm capable of much
writing and nor that I want to do any
writing part. I hope
[inaudible] I said what?
Think aloud to you and
to Kate, you a quarter
home hospice, um,
fatality well require an amount of care
today,
intravenous nursing things beyond
what you and Kate can provide.
And this in turn should reduce you
who knew to be
my friends and comforters.
Oh, one last scar. Attempting my appetite.
Can you bring me in and
disrupt the top category?
Just to mention there
is also chicken soup.
Yes. All right. I probably
should have some dick quit.
Throw a little of each
[inaudible].
Two weeks later on August 30th, 2015,
Oliver sacks died at home
in the last seven months of his life,
he wrote and published nine pieces,
and there were many, many more that
he started, wasn't able to finish.
And some of the essays he wrote are now
in a new collection published after he
died called the river of consciousness.
And that's just out the readers
that you heard in the story. Uh,
we're re radio labyrinth,
enemy Q and Simon Adler and Bethel hop
t thanks also to Mike Pash cash for
engineering help. And this piece
was produced by Carla Murphy.